good afternoon councilors staff and
those of us who are joining us online um
I'll open this uh hearing for the
general policies Reserve management plan
uh there are no apologies to have been
made aware of um just a not for those
joining online we have had a couple of
people who were going to be presenting
to us today uh uh unable to attend uh
one person who was going to be our last
speaker we asked to come forward so
we're waiting on them to arrive and
another who we've been unable to make
contact with um so what I'm going to do
is adjourn the hearing until they arrive
and we will resume hopefully within the
next 10 to 15 minutes we are
Jed
you can
tell
the money
2ch come and have a seat uh councils
I'll reconvene the
hearing uh the live stream's resumed
once again um Karen if you like to come
up and have a seat J you feel free to
join them one of those will tip
backwards wildly really
no thanks for taking the time and
respond responding to a call to please
come now because we've had a few people
withdraw so uh you've got um the full
attention of all of council B one uh
thank you very much for your written
submission which we've had the chance to
read through uh this is your opportunity
to speak to it normally we're pretty
tight on the old time thing but I've
been presented with a degree of
flexibility this afternoon so really the
the floor is
yours
um to thank you very much for this
opportunity to come and speak to our
submission um as I said I'm J do general
manager of regional leadership and
performance at active Southland and I'd
like to introduce my colleague Karen
wall who's um with us for special
projects at the moment so I'll hand over
to Karen thank you K everybody nice to
be here um I've had a long connection
with inago through my wife um and we've
kind of settled here about six weeks ago
so I'm pretty fresh into the role so
it's quite nice to be here uh kind of
making some connections and meeting
people and getting the opportunity to
speak to you um for active s and this is
a slightly new way of working um we are
really trying to lift our focus more
into that strategic space and work more
strategically with ICC as well uh we've
got a raft of values that are important
to us and trying to ensure that we are
kind of moving up from scratching around
the edges to try to support you guys to
really making Vago a better place to
live work and play is a is going to be a
key Focus for us moving forward um we've
really valued the opportunity to work
with your Parks team um to feed into the
into this process um currently and so
far we felt our feedback has been really
well listened to and we're seeing some
changes that we'd like to see in that
document already which is fantastic and
we'd really like to see this way of
working continue not only with your
Parks team but with other uh facets and
and teams within Council as we think we
can support you guys um really well to
connect with our communities and to to
really kind of help continue to move in
the Carle forward um this coming back to
the the r&p specifically we feel that
the document so far and the state that
it's in already creates great guidance
for community and you guys as a as a
regulatory Authority for those reserves
so we think that there's a way that it
can can really help to
make Clarity and a better understanding
of how reserves could be used for those
who have got um lease agreement those
who use them recreationally and for
those who um regularly lose your
reserves through Sport and active
participation
opportunities um our core Focus areas
which you can kind of see if you have an
understanding of our our strategy but we
really tried to pull them out so it's
quite simple for for other organizations
such as the councils to understand so
our first one for the purpose of this
document is active transport so ensuring
that our reserves are connected and
they're built in a way that allows
people to to walk skateboard scooter
bike to get around the city it's a
really safe way of doing so and it meets
our overarching ambition and goal which
is to get more people more active so
it's better to be on a bike in a nice
safe Reserve than it is to be satting
your you kind of sat we don't have too
much traffic here fortunately it's one
of my favorite things about being here
but better to be on a bike than in a you
sat of traffic lights and if you're away
from Cars when you're doing that that's
a much more pleasurable experience which
means you're more likely to do it with
your family and you're more likely to do
it more often um our second point is
Universal Design so we've got a a cool
Focus as an organization on disability
and inclusion which um I think is
fantastic my background is in that space
I worked at Tonga city council for a
number of years as an inclusive cities
officer um and I think Universal Design
is a great way to ensure we're including
everybody um doesn't matter if you're a
wheelchair user doesn't matter if you're
a m with a new pram or a delivery guy
hauling a box of uh new laptops into the
city council's new office you make it
easy for people to get in you're
included you feel valued and our public
spaces and parks are fantastic places to
do that and they really signal to your
community that you are included you are
valued and we want you here um what I
would encourage um you guys to ask
questions of your staff is around
wording where we're unintentionally
creating caveats to design people out so
words such as um where possible where
there's an identified need they end up
unintentionally designing people out of
spaces because you find an excuse not to
do it because someone hasn't told us we
need to do it means we often don't do it
because where possible means if you find
a barrier we just don't bother so let's
try and rephrase those words and be like
we want you here it doesn't matter what
you need is we want you here we see you
we value you um we're not going to say
these three Parks you can come to if you
use a wheelchair but the rest we don't
really want you at because that's what
you're unintentionally saying when you
find use those phrases um Southland
based on older um Census Data because
the new stuff hasn't been really
released very well um is that sou does
have a higher rate of disability than
the rest of the country and as your own
assumptions um for the future Lookout we
do also have an older uh increased or
higher rate of Elder Elder people in
this city so accessibility and inclusion
are going to become more and more needed
and prevalent in this city so we can if
we build things in now it's it's going
to save us money in the future it's
going to mean we've got a a place that
people want to stay it's got a means
we're going to have a place that people
feel valued feel seen and feel
comfortable in which is really important
um feeding into that is is Park
Furniture so really for us we've pulled
that out specifically for the reserves
what we're talking about is healthy
active and utilized reserves places
where people feel safe where they want
to stay when they feel they can come
with their grandparents or grandchildren
or wider family to to celebrate
themselves to be active um and we think
this can be done through being proactive
making decisions that lead to creating
safe inclusive spaces so looking at
where small changes can be made to um to
benches or to foot paths um utilizing
shade is a really important piece of
work a lot of cities around the country
are looking at um shade planning because
our summers are getting hotter and
hotter and hotter which means that it's
not safe to be outside for so long so
having somewhere you pull your
5-year-old aside sit in the shade and
drink some water from the water fountain
that's in the reserve is a really really
valuable asset and needs to be built
into um our Reserve planning because
otherwise our natural our beautiful
natural environment is going to become
unusable before too long um we have
worked with the council and other um
councils across the region to develop um
the sports sou and sports build strategy
and the spaces and places strategies
which are um really fantastic pieces of
work it's really critical for us that we
see those mentioned and referenced um in
this uh r&p general purpose r&p to
ensure that we're not wasting our energy
that stuff is being cross-pollinated and
that those ideas are
relevant um I'll try and move myself on
quickly now sorry um play is
increasingly important you can see that
through sport New Zealand um their
strategies you can see it through the
work we're doing and you guys have done
by recently appointing Damen puddle in a
play activation role um it's really
important that play doesn't just focus
on children Everybody Plays um
intergenerational play is critical and I
think ensuring that that is captured and
is a key theme that runs through this
documentation is going to be really
important for making um in viago in
Southland a place where you can live
work and play we talk about it a lot
what do we mean by play and I'd
encourage you to um to really think
about that and ensure that it's
captured um and not only only in
reserves that was my last little note
their play happens everywhere it's not
just in playgrounds it's on our streets
it's in our malls um it's at home it's
all over the place so let's think about
it in in the broadest sense possible um
we were really encouraged to see mention
of the um siped principles so that's um
crime prevention through environmental
design so it's not just CT CCTV cameras
they are useful they are a great tool
but having
activated places that are filled with
people is the best way to prevent crime
so let's look at how we can do that in
our parks and reserves as well as our
Civic precincts and our city centers um
and the last Point we've got here was um
around climate change so we're seeing
more and more pressure on our reserves
whether it's flooding or um saturated
ground during the winter or dry harsh
conditions in the summer it's
increasingly having an impact on where
and how people are able to um enjoy our
parks and reserves so we'd really
encourage um Council to look at some
other work that can be done around um
asset resilience and planning and
development to ensure that we are moving
forward with confidence and we're not
putting plans in place for reserves that
actually are just going to be underwater
whether they're flood planes um or
whether in summer they're going to be so
dry we're going to struggle to get grass
coverage in the future so have a look
see where we can Implement that into
this so that we're ahead of that curve
and that's all from me and let's just
you've got anything to
add thank you Kieran and um welcome to
Southland uh obviously your former role
in local government makes you very poach
I mean um
approachable um C can I ask you've
singled out the the the where possible
terminology that we VI so can I can I
ask you to expand on that and go well
how do we cope with inadvertent barriers
that are there currently that we need do
we need to recognize them um but with a
A View to how we overcome them I think
that's a really a really good question I
think um often the number of barriers
that we create in our society are we
we've created them so which means we can
actually unpick them um which is really
valuable to understand there are always
going to be barriers that are
insurmountable at times however um I can
think of a couple of examples where you
can can you can navigate that you're not
necessarily going to create full access
but you can create some so um in my role
at Tonga city council we had people that
wanted to enjoy the beach which is our
most beautiful resource other than mole
in that in that City and we worked and
looked extensively and found some um
Beach matting which are bright blue mats
that were designed for wheelchair and
pram use and we spent not a huge amount
of money on about 200 meters worth of
beach matting and we rolled that out and
we worked with Surf lifesaving and other
organizations so that wheelchair users
could have access to the beach because
currently they're excluded from going to
the beach of their family which also
means if you're the parent of a child
and you're a disabled adult your child
might not get to go to the beach with
their parent and that is a huge
opportunity loss for them as well as you
um and the other barrier I mentioned is
mole which is a beautiful Monga at the
end of the Headland 210 meters above sea
level and you do it in a very short
period of time and uh we'd work the
council had worked extensively with the
um mole trust which when the land was
transferred back to um moldi ownership
through quite an extensive uh period of
time and process but some of the work
there was around removing vehicle access
from Mo to protect um to protect it
which meant that kind of arrangement
where the surf life saving club would
run someone up in their little buggy to
the top so that they could access and
see the views was no longer possible so
we worked with the trust to F again find
an Innovative solution which was a a
buggy that has how the best way I
describe it basically a really really
flash wheelbarrow with a B with one
wheel underneath it I'm comfortable seat
had an electric battery that meant that
you weren't pushing it it kind of pulled
itself um two people at the front two
people at the back someone in the middle
and you could navigate the tracks and
trails as a as a family or a fun or a
group of friends to get that person to
the top so I really believe where
there's a will there's away if we use
words like where possible we're already
going it's too hard so it will always be
possible there are going to be
exceptions to that but if you take the
approach of innovation you can find a
way to achieve it and it's not always
very expensive I I think there's often a
exception that inclusive access is hard
it's expensive but that's not
necessarily the case great thanks Karen
Grant then Leslie and then Tom yeah
thanks CH two questions one um
particular thought to how we activate
different res of areas within the city
probably in my mind it's Queens Park
some of the areas in South City but
equally Sandy Point um you know which I
think everyone around this table
recognizes a significant strategic
resource for our city in terms of
wellness and health and play and all
those sorts of things but be really Keen
to hear your thoughts or to get insights
back at some stage around how we can
leverage up those assets for the benefit
of all community and the second thing is
around who pays
there there's clearly benefit right for
wellness for activity for play all those
sorts of things is it a burden and I
think through active New Zealand would
be really interested in what their view
is is does it just fall on local rate
payers what is the central government's
role in supporting initiatives
locally and if you use that example of
Sandy Point to activate that in some of
the ways you've talked about with Tong
um so that people benefit and we do get
those long-term benefits of you know of
every reserves and activity for for
local people but it not necessarily
Falls to local people to pay yeah I
think two two really good questions and
I'll start start off by I've Trav I've
lived in a lot of places in the last 10
years in New Zealand and overseas and
Queens Park is one is a genuine Jewel
and this city should be so proud of that
that Reserve it's incredible um and I
think it's it's naturally activated to a
point but I agree with you is we should
be exploring how to make the most out of
that Jew and how to ensure that that
residents here are really enjoying it
and getting the opportunity to because
I'm sure there's there's a lot of
tourists that drive into town and see
the sign Park up and and it's probably
the one thing that they remember most
about going to Cargo potentially how
many of our residents are using that
Weekly how many are really really
getting the best benefit out of that and
I think that would absolutely six weeks
into my job but absolutely be a piece of
work we' be really Keen to work with you
on around how we can best activate that
and think about um kind of get some Blue
Sky Thinking we've got a really you know
historic and beautiful Reserve here but
what can we do to ensure that it stays
relevant that people are using it that
people are valuing it and that it's fit
for purpose for the inment of future um
as for who invests in in parks and
Reserve moving forward I think it's
something that specifically can be
looked at around Partnerships
um simplistically you know if it's if
it's for the residents residents to some
extent will always be expected to pay
for things I guess but I don't know the
answers around um specifically what
opportunities there might be from
central government funding to support
that I'm sure there are some um and
again I think it's something we could um
through our spaces and places portfolio
and other elements around active
transport and play could suddenly look
at um working with the counil and
understanding I think it's a role that
act of New Zealand could take forward to
the government on the behalf of local
authorities and working with local
government New Zealand you know because
we all know the benefits but you know
just everything keeps falling back to
the rate pay infrastructure water you
that's you know we all see the benefits
and want these things but we' got to
have a fair share of Revenue yeah I
think um nice question Grant
sorry um sport New Zealand I think is
who you're referring to and definitely
they see themselves as a player and that
and having advocating um definitely fact
of South and how ref find kind of
strategic actions and points talks to
insights and giving you the evidence and
and triing things kind of that safe to
fail because we can through funding
routes through sport New Zealand to try
to activate these areas so there's
definitely opportunity and we're we're
really ke to explore what that might
look CL yeah thanks Jess leslee thanks
very much Mr chair Karen first of all
congratulations on the beach meting and
to rer I have family there and I've seen
it in use and it definitely has made a
difference so my question
um where would you start with the
Universal Design principles that's a a
great question the number one having
spent time in a in a council with that
being a core component of my job the the
starting point is actually getting the
organization to Value it um because it's
simple things like um roading Engineers
caring about it knowing about it
thinking about how they designed people
into spaces um thinking about how your
planning team what their knowledge base
is around Universal Design
um there's some odd little um design
features you see around the country you
might walk into a new bath I it's
probably example here we built a
beautiful new bathroom and a lovely
reserve and you go into the the standard
stores and you've got sensor Taps and
nice clean everything's fantastic you go
into your accessible toilet and you've
got a leave tap because the code written
in 1980s says you need a leave tap in
your bathroom for access your accessible
bathroom not considering that technology
Chang is an actually a sens tap works
best for everybody so if you've got the
knowledge in the region and you've got
people that are invested in Universal
Design on your roster as staff you will
start to see those little changes made
because they'll just question it like we
can do better than that the code says
this but this is supersedes the code and
that's a great way of looking at um how
Council can influence the design and
functionality of the city as a whole um
and then you can look at um key little
projects when something's coming up that
might be a you know multi-purpose site
that's developed in the future ensuring
that one of the key values of that piece
of work is Universal Design and that
those tools are implemented throughout
it there are um really good examples of
desired GS in Oakland uh city council
design guide and um LIF Mark which do a
whole lot of stuff around inclusive
design as well um but I think or ICC as
an organization taking some ownership
and pride of that in the work that
they're doing upskill ing um yourselves
to some extent as well so you've got a
good understanding of what it is and
asking your teams when stuff gets
presented to you what are we doing to
include this has Universal Design be
considered is is a really key part of
that process um and I think the
influence can be very broad broads
spread and it doesn't need to cost the
rate payer or Council a huge amount if
that's what you're influencing because
it's thought leadership and it's around
wanting to include everybody in our city
thank you very much Tom
to some extent Leslie's question was
very similar meain but I I I guess the
um the universal access issues something
that you know is probably always at the
back of your minds but how do you bring
it to the front of your mind so that
it's something that you're actively
thinking about and and I guess from
where we are today to where we might
aspire to be you know as as a
combination of policy and funding isn't
it but on the matter of policy um I just
wonder whether you know that to the
extent to which you've been able to look
at the policies of the city this city
and I guess specifically parks and and
Recreation to to what extent do they
point us in the right direction with
with respect to universal access or if
we got a lot more work to do you know do
they not point us our all in that
direction I think from what I've seen so
far there probably isn't an arrow that's
pointing Us in that direction I think
it's something that we could with the
right intention we can probably quickly
Rectify in terms of policy which is the
key driver I think one of the things
around inclusive design is taking the
decision to do it or not do it away from
people so you build it into your policy
you build it into your strategies and it
gets done like magic It generally costs
you maybe 1% of your project cost more
to in to utilize Universal Design
principles um 1 to 2% so it's around
that the spot on it's that policy key
that policy is key and is the driving
force and I think from what I've seen um
of the updated um GP uh general purpose
Resource Management plan has been
mentioned in there more as a result of
the feedback from myself and ccs and
others um which is really good however
you know there's a raft of policy that
we should be looking to update and
include this in as it really will um
point us in that direction moving
forward thank you m clar um just a cple
things um you you made a couple of
statements that seem to conflict with me
so you sort of went down the line of
saying um all reserves should be of
similar access I guess as opposed to
just two or three big ones so in our
city we've got 70 plus reserves and
Parks um probably per capita higher than
anywhere else so um the cost of having
wheelchair access to all 70 reserves and
parks would be
astronomical my question is that would
be do you not think people should access
those reserves no I didn't say that what
I'm saying is if you want to make um
disability access to all 74 parks and
given that some of these Parks do not
lend themselves to people with mobility
issues for so um there has to be some
limitation on where you can afford to
put in because there is a significant
cost it' be more than 1% of a project
cost of alwayss to do a bush track out
through Sandy Point that allow people to
mountain bike SL Walker dogs SL walk and
then I start considering Wheelchairs and
other things as well it would be more
than 1% of the cost I think um you take
an approach where you your aspiration is
to design people in and you I wouldn't
be suggesting that we go out tomorrow
and all all 70 OD reserves are fixed
overnight because the cost would be huge
if you if you take that approach but
building those values into your design
principles into your
your outcomes means that over time we
will see that change so yes we may work
with ccs to Target or other agencies to
Target you know what cabs are first off
the rank um but we will then Implement
these values into projects moving
forward there will always be some
challenges there will always be some
cost but you I think it's really
important to consider when we put cost
in front of of people as the only
barrier or the only important asset
um where where are we heading as a
society if we're doing that it's a big
question it's not for today but I think
it's really important when we're talking
about policy and setting a direction um
to previous counselor's
points so two other questions for you
thank questions yeah absolutely so um
you made reference to sports and
maintenance of sports field and other
things so um what's your take on the
future of Junior sports
like um I can tell you that all sports
and I mean all sports with one exception
or two exceptions which is football and
the climbing fraternity that climb on
the wall down at the stadium are in
reclining numbers so how do we how do we
factor in being active and giving access
to facilities that are
changing I think it's a that's a really
good question and it is a a true
observation that uh participation in
sport generally is declining um part of
our roomate as an organization is to
ensure people stay active uh we don't
have all of the answers and I think
there's so many interesting examples
where if you look back 20 years ago I
think the idea of having a Frisbee Golf
Course aligned with Queens Park Golf
Club would have been mindblowing to
people but that's a key way that people
are still active and I think that's a
great example of how the changing nature
of sport and Recreation activi
what the changing face of it looks like
and we have to be prepared to be uh
flexible and and ensure that we design
spaces to be flexible to flex the future
needs that we're maybe not seeing yet um
to make sure that those places and the
investment in that stays
relevant and so the last question is a
statement and a question just for
Darren's perspective unlike lesie I have
walked across that blue meting at Papa
reach um but the other issue is that we
tend to Cluster the disability sector as
one sector when in fact it's not as you
will know and so one of the issues I
guess we deal with Council which I'd
like your thoughts on is that the
disability sector quite rightly claim
they have about 23% of the community are
disabled in one shape or another all the
disability sector um but that covers a
huge range so there'll be people here
that form that category because they
wear glasses for sake but then when you
talk about the de and the Blind and
other things as well it's a very complex
area so how do we break down that Lobby
group for to a bit of words and
facilitate for them when we think about
reserves and Parks it's it's a very good
question and the number the 23 or 27%
that come from the Census Data are
self-identified disability so you look
at the questions and some of them are
can you tie your shoelace is unassisted
um do you do you believe your vision is
poor enough for so you're right it's a
very broad spectrum when you go from
that and you look in you include um your
intellectual impairment groups your
physical impairment groups it's very
Broad and people do have um some
differences on how they think the world
should look um my suggestion is that
Universal Design principles in terms of
reserves and the role that Council can
play is a really great way of of of
including everybody because it's very
hard to meet individual needs um to talk
to one person and they say I want a c d
talk to a second person and they want um
you know one two and three so they're
completely different they're not even
talking the same language at times and
that um my observation from my previous
role would be at council at times you
can end up listening to individual
preferences not what's better for the
collective and I would suggest that for
where we are at the moment Universal
Design principles is the best Collective
approach that can be taken to cater for
as many people as possible thank you
Trish the um just with reference to
Queens Park to Queens
Park I love that you see it how we need
to activate it more last Tuesday night I
went this is leading to a question isn't
it TR it is excellent it is I we had
home past Queens Park and the council
with a rotary group had arranged for
Halloween in the park thousand kids
across town not just one area what can
you do
it's probably not quite relevant but
what can you do to make sure that kind
of thing happens with Partnerships
because we were doing eff um but we need
the community to also come to there yeah
and I think that's um a great example of
where you have to look at Cross
organization Partnerships and where um
active South an ICC can formalize some
of our working together around those
projects and where um it might may not
may or may not be our role to do
particular parts of that but we have
great relationships with a number of
community groups um to bring them to the
table as well to ensure that those
activations are interesting relevant
vibrant and we're getting people using
our reserves um as you say because
that's it's such a nice feeling when you
walk through a space and there's people
there having a nice time it's sort of a
question NN I promise I'll ask a
question good
um I recognize that your brief is to
talk about active activity but
given
that we're all different which you've
acknowledged as
well in this particular conversation
where does challenging come in so if and
I don't mean to be disrespectful of
anybody because I'm really Limited in
mobility in some ways but where does
challenging people's abilities come in
this conversation because um some of it
in our ambition to be inclusive can we
actually dumb it
down um or does that mean that the city
shouldn't be providing the more
challenging experiences that should be
somebody else this is not meant to be
offensive to anybody it's my thinking is
where does where does the um the more
challenging walks or where does the
the me example of the climbing frames
where does that fit in this it's an
activity but it's never going to be
accessible to everybody you know should
we exclude them because it's not it's a
great question and I think um that there
are organizations such as Recreation Al
that are doing some great work in that
space they're building Frameworks and
they're building um examples of how you
can can include people in spaces but
without taking the challenge away from
it so um I think it's really my personal
perspective having whated um Paralympics
New Zealand as well is that you need
people to challenge themselves you need
to create environments where people feel
that they can push their limits and
sometimes fail that's really important
and where or where or where it is not
the the council's role is probably to
look at the evidence that's out there
and to decide where investment is is
spent and to ensure that where possible
we're creating um inclusive environments
it doesn't mean that there's not
challeng in there it doesn't mean
there's not scaled opportunities you
know there's um if I think about I don't
activity I do on the weekend night for a
run at Sea with bush but if I wasn't I'm
not particularly fit if I was less fit I
could have done half a loop rather than
a full loop so it's scalable and it's
flexible and I think that's how we can
look at um providing challenge to people
at different
uh physical ability levels um and ensure
that everybody has an opportunity to be
included they may choose not to be they
may choose not to access those reserves
but if they do is there something they
can access is there something they can
be a part of um and from a strategy
perspective looking at the evidence that
is is available to us it's being done by
good work done by other organizations
such as sport New Zealand and um active
uh Recreation Al so if we had a t Target
of um say 75% of our reserves being
fully
accessible which may or may not be
easily achievable but for instance I
look at um o Gardens and not all of them
are freely accessible because of the
inclines and the steps um but if we made
sure that one of the Aon Gardens was
fully accessible would that be meeting
it being fair or you know because
there's reasons why they're not
accessible including stock Banks which
provide Safety and Security for our
infrastructure so you know I think it'd
be um naive of me to try and give
specific examples I don't know the
reserve and I think um there may or may
not be design design solutions that
could overcome those barriers and that
would be where I'd start can we design
our way out of the challenge um if not
what's the best we can do and that may
be part of it is accessible that maybe
we can completely make it completely
accessible with some really smart design
people smarter than me can come up with
that um but it's about looking at it
with that if you take that lens of can
we do it you will end somewhere you'll
end up somewhere that's better than
never asking the question that would be
my thank you for challenging my thinking
and thank you for coming and presenting
I appreciate it no worries thank you
kieren thank you Jess uh we may have
gone from four to one uh person or
organization speaking to submission but
I think um the quality of your
presentation has been uh impressive and
and welcome so thank you very much for
taking the time thank and once again
welcome to town you have until next week
to familiarize yourself with all our
reserves councilors that brings us to
the recommendations because we're not
deliberating today uh we were just uh
was just scheduled to hear the
submissions so the recommendations are
one that we received the reports general
policies Reserve management plan
hearings that we receive the submissions
including the submission that we've
heard we agree to receive a late
submission received from Brit bar who
note the summary of submissions and the
hearing schedule which was reduced to
just uh Kieran and Jess from active
South move those by Leslie and
Evelyn uh any discussion on that bearing
in mind that discussion on the issues
raised will actually come up when we get
to
deliberation if not put the motion all
favor I thank you for those who had the
pleasure of joining us on Zoom thank you
for your attention and I will adjourn
this
here
that